tibilisi the Georgian capital
Russia's war against Ukraine has changed
the South Caucasus Nation
the signs of popular opposition to
Putin's aggression are everywhere
now in their midst young men who have
left Russia fearful of being forced to
join the war their country is waging
against Ukraine
some may call me a traitor but I think
those who go to war are the Traders
they're betraying their Homeland and
Humanity
so who am I betraying
Putin yes I'm betraying him and now I've
run away from him
I'm against this war in this conflict
and completely for Ukraine they want to
send me to my death for Putin's
Ambitions for this notorious Russian
world that's so alien to me
right
[Music]
thank you
my name's Alexander I'm from St
Petersburg and I'm 26 years old
[Music]
Ukraine in February he joined a protest
rally and was detained when Putin
ordered the mobilization in late
September he decided it was time to
leave he packed his things and fled
I live in our hippie Community here this
is my bike I cycled over the Russian
Georgian border on it
he had to wait at the border for two
days
[Music]
I was afraid they wouldn't let me out of
Russia all along the queue police were
checking papers and threatening to issue
conscription orders but I didn't care I
just wanted to reach my destination
when we crossed the border the sun rose
these mountains freedom
once in tabilisi Alexander was in luck
this is Uncle Enrique
he took us in and gave us clothes
[Music]
I feel sorry for them
they don't want to fight or to die for
Putin
immobilization forced him to come here
they didn't think it would come to this
people running away like Rats from a
sinking ship
they're all intelligent and nice
I don't know who is staying in Russia
unlike Baltic countries in Finland
Georgia hasn't closed its borders to
Russians many Georgians take a skeptical
view of this what if Putin's supporters
or even spies are entering the country
unchecked
she's such a big fantastic change in the
amount of people here
that was 2008 they have invaded two
parts of Georgia I recently cannot be
warm and like generous towards these
people first of all when they coming to
communicate with you talk with you they
starting to talk with you in Russian bro
it's a Georgia we can
pick English right in some respectful
it's so rude
[Music]
of course I appreciate that I'm a guest
here and that my country is also guilty
because of its actions against Georgia I
understand that this could be a trigger
for some Georgians and that they might
be suspicious of me because of that but
up to now everyone's been friendly
[Music]
my name is Alexi and I'm 32 years old
in the chuvash Republic
Alexi was a professional Soldier until
2016 an experienced Gunner he was needed
on the front line
I was surprised that the conscription
order wasn't sent immediately it arrived
after I'd gone
my sister sent me a photo on telegram
they were too late you won't get me
[Music]
he's been in Georgia for a few weeks now
trying to make the best of things after
his years in the military Alexi wanted
nothing more to do with the Russian army
he preferred the life of a migrant
worker
he simply doesn't understand compatriots
who don't resist the mobilization
you can't imagine what awaits them in
Wars
everything there is just chaos
rusting weapons drinking brawling just
seeing it brings tears to your eyes
they'd sent me to the front there'd only
be one way out to be taken prisoner
foreign
[Music]
his mother would have preferred him to
fight
my mother said she would even go to war
in my place
she believes NATO and the U.S want to
conquer us I said what you're saying is
a huge lie all off the TV
he feels safe airing his political views
in Georgia
Alexi wants to go back to Russia but
only after the end of the war and a
regime change
[Music]
Alexander has made a number of friends
in Tbilisi he's still living at Enriquez
and is looking for work
his girlfriend will be joining him soon
also in Tbilisi Alexi is looking for new
accommodation and keeping afloat with
casual work his mother has now accepted
his decision to leave Russia they talk
but not about the war